I am very keen to talk about Brett said
but first I was interested to get your
thoughts on the appalling events that
happened in Westminster this week you
were Deputy Prime Minister for five
years and you've been in those top level
briefings how do you think Teresa mode
handled it I think she's handled it well
I think she's handled it well and you're
quite right i sat with her David Cameron
and unfortunately in many meetings for
five years trying to work out what to do
with and how to prepare for exactly that
kind of eventualities and I don't want
to make it it sounds callous but I'm
afraid everybody was expecting something
like this to to happen and the emergency
services and the police and you know the
the kind of nerve system in Whitehall
and the Prime Minister I think reacted
the right way not least by signaling as
she did immediately in the aftermath of
that horrific attack that we shouldn't
immediately lurch to sort of try and
reach for new off-the-shelf solutions
for what is a very very difficult
problem which is very difficult to know
what's going on in someone's head
particularly someone in this appears to
be in this case who's acted largely
perhaps not exclusively alone you say
that we shouldn't lurch for
off-the-shelf solutions at the same time
that it's pretty shocking isn't it not
only zone armed with a car and a knife
can get inside Parliament's grounds I
mean surely there is a case for arming
policemen at Parliament now oh I think I
think of course there will be now be a
review on exactly those kind of things I
think clearly a case to look at what
they call the outer perimeter so that
literally the first line of defence if
you like for the parliamentary estate
and there were if I understand correctly
armed officers there for a while than
they were like brought back a bit
should they be brought forward again I
don't think you know politicians should
start sort of trying to sort of populate
this debate with their own personal
views but that's exactly something which
should be subject to review by people
who know what they're talking about and
we should we should be inclined to then
implement what they say but but the but
your characterization of it is is very
appropriate you know in an open free
society if someone's prepared to kill
themselves and just armed in a higher
car and I've been a rudimentary with the
kitchen knife they can do an enormous
amount of harm and we must do everything
we can to protect ourselves and
protected
and crucially protect our values but we
do unfortunately live in a in a world
where if you want to retain an open
democratic society you can't make
yourself safe a hundred percent of the
time and that's exactly the kind of
that's the difficulty in this debate and
I thought that was appropriately and
well reflected by the prime minister in
the immediate aftermath of the attack
you've of course been quite a strong
champion of civil liberties in
Parliament but isn't it time really for
to get real to look at the attacks that
we're facing the fact that there's
security services dealing with five
hundred and fifteen live cases at any
time they say that they've sorted
thirteen potential attacks as since 2013
we need to get tight on giving the
security services the tools they need
don't we have you been wrong in the past
on civil liberties no we've given them
the tools including myself in fact I've
pushed through controversial legislation
against the irony of ironies resistance
from David Davis who even brought the
government at the time to call precisely
to give the security services the tools
that they need without an ending
end-to-end encryption for social media
services like well that's quite
different this is the so-called snoopers
Charter which it has now been pushed
through by this government
I don't feel now and I don't feel and I
didn't feel in government that that was
appropriate no other developed society
has done it Denmark I think tried it
once and found that they hoovered up so
much useless data vast volumes of it
they didn't know what to do with it it
hasn't been proven as a proportionate as
a proportionate response to precisely
the kind of attack you're talking about
but look if you want to make your
society a hundred percent safe you're
right we could impose a curfew at 7 p.m.
we could we could we could you know put
controls on people which would be
entirely unacceptable in a free society
but precisely the kind of thing that the
attacker on Wednesday sought to do is to
is to shake our own confidence in our
own democratic values and it and that he
did that by attacking the home of our
democracy we should be very careful to
be fair to the Prime Minister I think
she has been careful in the words she
has chosen since then not two not two in
total understandably wanting to react to
these horrific events actually do so in
a way which might might raise a question
mark about some of those democratic
values that we hold so dear and let's
talk about brexit now the Lib Dems have
been support
a second referendum on the deal at you
and your leader we're at this March the
brexit anti brexit march yesterday and
the Lib Dems have amended the brexit
bill are you in denial that it's going
to happen no I think if the brexit ears
last summer had spelt out to the British
people exactly what kind of brexit they
were pursuing if there'd been an
agreement between your previous guest
Nigel Ferrara Boris Johnson Michael Gove
and the rest of them about not only
wanting to take the European Union quite
clear about leaving a single market what
they know they weren't at what a flat
George Osborne was the other side not
that what I'm saying is the debate no I
never got and you never got no one
looking this program got a clear
manifesto from Nigel Ferrara Boris
Johnson Michael Gove on a crossbar party
basis saying we want you to leave the
European Union and this is how we will
do it so in other words there's a huge
question now over the next two years
about what kind of brakes it hard or
soft inside or outside the single market
are we gonna abide by the European Court
of Justice what kind of changes to
freedom of movement what kind of changes
to our universities what kind of changes
to our farmers our fishing and so on and
so forth all of that is going to affect
almost every aspect of our lives once we
know what it means in practice rather
than the utopian promises that all will
be brilliant and all will be well of
course we think it is right not a second
referendum that the British people
should then have their say because
there's going to be a deal right or at
least I hope there is there's going to
be a deal who then has to decide upon
that deal is it the politicians is it to
reason may on her own or is it the
people and we think quite rightly in
keeping with the decision last last
summer it should be the people and by
the way this is not some exotic Lib Dem
invention David Davis John redwood other
Euroskeptics like this have for years
been arguing precisely this is a
two-step process make the decision to
leave and then take a final decision in
the hands of the pieces on how you do
some people listening to this will think
you sound a bit like a bad loser here
that the Lib Dems lost dozens of seats
at the last election you've got many of
you got booted out of Parliament you
lost their referendum and now you're
effectively trying to stop democracy I
mean I can understand why you perhaps
don't like the results of democracy very
much but you have to accept it don't you
I don't actually accept that 16.1
million people almost 50%
people who voted last summer are having
their dreams their aspirations and their
needs so some early brushed under the
carpet and I personally think that the
choices the government's taken since
last summer our choices which they need
to take it I believe that the Prime
Minister and this government could have
taken a much much more moderate view in
trying to reach out to not least by the
way young people who voted in
overwhelming numbers for a different
future it's a very perilous path for a
country I think to take such a momentous
decision on its own future against the
explicit stated wishes of those people
who have to inhabit that future the
young 70 percent of youngsters but who
voted and they voted in huge numbers
voted to remain so surely actually the
duty on the government he's not a shout
down people like me to say how do you
reach out to the whole country by
pursuing this self harming hard brexit
making these choices which they needn't
have taken they're only doing to satisfy
people like Nigel Faraj the government I
think is not actually reflecting the
very divided opinion that was that
emerged in the referendum I'm quite
interested as well to get a sense of how
is for you to be in Parliament now
because under your leadership the Lib
Dems got absolutely pummeled soon they
have like the last election you lost 48
of your 56 feet and now that you seem to
be crawling your way back slightly so do
you feel that the problem was you know I
don't think so that for a moment if you
just look at if you look at smaller
center-left party to go into coalition
with center-right parties at a time of
austerity I'm afraid they're getting
hammered everywhere we do they look at
your felt then if it was that simple if
people were just how is my fault from
that you know then then all would be
well because you just have to get rid of
people who say it's it's much more
complex than that the the center-left
party in the netherlands last week just
got hammered for the same reason so the
Labour Party in Ireland there is a there
is a real issue for coalition
governments and the way in which for
various reasons for which of course I
take a share of responsibility the
smaller parties tend to get the
disproportionate share of the blame for
the bad stuff for the larger parties get
the disproportionate credit for the good
stuff I don't complain about that that
seems to be quite a common pattern now
across across Europe but I always
thought the Liberal Democrats would
bounce back far faster I find you know
as I travel around the country lots of
people are now saying to me that they
appreciate the way in which the
Democrats fought very hard to anchor the
country in the center ground over five
difficult years they don't like this
very ideological approach to brexit
taken by this government they want a
voice against it they're not getting it
from jeremy corbyn's Labour Party they
are getting it from the Liberal
Democrats from Tim Farron and that's why
I think we're doing better and will
continue to do better in the years ahead
okay Nick Clegg thanks very much for
coming on the show